- All right, let's finish
up with something super fun.
Ripped from the pages of social media,
this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
As you might know, the Houston Astros
won the World Series last week.
(audience cheers)
It's clear, when it comes to team sports,
every member of the
club plays a vital role.
So I wanna tell you
about a special teammate
on the Durham Bulls Minor League team.
His job is to grab the bats from the field
after each at-bat.
Check out Ripken the Bat Dog in action.
(baseball hit)
(crowd cheers)
(crowd cheers louder)
(game announcer over speaker)
(audience applauses)
- Now I can get into sports
when it comes to that. That's amazing.
I love that. We have
Ripken on the line now
along with his owner, Michael,
and the Assistant GM for
the Durham Bulls, Chip.
They watch on W-R-A-L TV at two.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] What's up y'all? How you doing?
- Hey Kelly.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I love Ripken so much.
So Michael, you trained Ripken, right?
- I did, I did.
Grew up training dogs my whole life,
or playing in the backyard
with my dogs my whole life.
And went off to college, played
a little college baseball.
And after college, opened
my own dog training company.
And thought it would
be a great combination
to kind of combine two of my loves,
dogs and sports. And so
Ripken kind of started off
as just a fun thing in the yard,
fetching little novelty bats.
And from there as he
grew, the bats got bigger,
and had him practicing
with my college bats.
And we got our first call by
the Holly Spring Salamanders
that led us to where we are
today with the Durham Bulls,
and I couldn't have dreamt
that it would be where we are now.
- Oh my God, it's so great.
I would've been the one losing my mind
in the crowd, by the way, every time.
Like as if it were brand new each time.
Chip, so you say Ripken
is an integral part
of home games, right?
- Oh, he's a huge part.
Fans absolutely love Ripken.
When Michael and Ripken get
here, they go on the concourse,
and they are absolutely
inundated with people.
(Kelly and crowd laugh)
They got their cards that
they're handing out and signing.
And a lot of dads will come up and say,
"Can I get one for my kid?"
And we all know they don't have any kids.
How many adults are doing
this for themselves?
It's pretty funny.
It's not just the fans that love Ripken.
It's the players too. We
have Miles Mastrobuoni,
who went up to the Bigs earlier this year,
but he would come and get
a good luck kiss every time
from Ripken and did phenomenal.
Good enough to be called up.
And so good that Ripken and the Bulls,
we won another title this year.
It sounds like Ripken's gonna get a ring.
(audience cheers)
Got his paw size, I think
he's all ready to go.
- Oh my gosh. Well thank y'all so much.
Thank you, Michael. Thank you, Chip.
Thank you, Ripken.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I'm liking the post right now.
(ding)
And that's not all, ya'll.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and just creating memories
for fans just like y'all.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars,
that's $500 each.
- Wow, that's awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- All right, make sure
and give Ripken a bone
or something with that.
Thank you guys so much.
(audience cheers)
Thank you to all our guests today
Luke Grimes, Wes Bentley, Walker Hayes,
Dominique, and Tove.
Y'all have a great day, and if it's not,
well try and change it.